yeah um so having a sense of purpose
cause or belief for our work
is what gives our work and frankly our
lives meaning um
you know when we die nobody wants the
the last
balance in their checking account
written on their tombstone you know
uh nobody wants the last title on their
last business card
on their tombstone we don't that's not
how we want to be remembered
we want to be remembered for the kind of
person we were in the lives of others
you know
devoted mother loving father you know
these kinds of things
um and and we want to know that our work
uh
had an impact in something bigger than
ourselves it's a very normal human thing
um unfortunately a lot of people don't
start to think about those things until
later in their lives
and i've heard this i usually hear this
from senior executives believe it or not
where they say you know i've had great
success and i've done all these things
but
but i don't want my i don't want my life
to end on this chapter
i would feel like i've done something
wrong you know
and they want to make sure that they're
that they do something
powerful and impactful in the lives of
others that that's how they want to
close the book on their lives
what i love about this young generation
is they're starting to think about those
kinds of things now
um you know it's not unique to a young
generation everybody wants their work to
matter and have meaning
i think our young generation is just
more vocal about it which is wonderful